um and uh that will vary from the nato
foreign ministers meetings the g7
foreign minister's meeting where i put
afghanistan on the agenda
through to the bilateral contacts with
the likes of turkey um through to un's
special envoy jean-paul noe
also bear in mind i appreciate there's a
lot of scrutiny about things like calls
this is taking place
along with a range of other
simmering issues which may or may not
bother up to crisis iraq
the situation there is very delicate
iran jcpoa negotiations the dual
national situation tax on shipping yemen
tigre somalia hong kong belarus ukraine
coupled with covert so i just make the
point very gently if i may
having a delegation and a division of
labor between ministers particularly my
senior ministers of state actually is an
essential part of the work we do foreign
secretary i agree with you absolutely
therefore may i ask very briefly
when was the last time a foreign
minister went to uzbekistan
went to uzbekistan
uh i'm not sure i'd have to check but
we've obviously been eating
a few countries when was the last time a
foreign minister went to tajikistan
again i don't have the
the visit
list but i'm very happy if you give me
your list to provide it for example in
uzbekistan of course given the need to
ensure
third party safe passage to third
countries
lord ahmed has been in touch with the
uzbek foreign minister i'm scheduled i
was supposed to speak to them today but
it's a national holiday i'll speak to
them
tomorrow so obviously we remain engaged
and if you would like to know the visits
very happy to come back to you i'm very
grateful it seems particularly relevant
because haiku mass was recently in
uzbekistan arranging the evacuation of
german people through
uh tashkent and it seems to be a route
that worked extremely effectively for
germany
although they have just closed the
border indeed they have now but the
germans got their people out first may i
just ask on the uh
clearly to speak to third country what
we are doing i'm just about to come to
that exact question um because
you will also have had uh
contact with of course our missions in
these countries uh before the 15th of
august in order uh to prepare for a
likely
fall of kabul or indeed a collapse of
the regime
[Music]
[Music]
and i've had discussions with uh various
different ambassadors who have joined
meetings but actually the way that it
works is that the ambassadors feed
through their advice we obviously see it
it's triaged up but we get it together
it's triaged up and and brought together
so i get a full picture and that's done
through
for example during the time when we had
the emergency response team operating
the evacuation
and indeed before
my
director for afghanistan nigel casey and
also tom drew my director general
the reason i asked these questions is
because in your media round yesterday
you said that it wasn't the
responsibility of the foreign office uh
for the errors in intelligence that have
led us to this
position
and i just wondered i mean clearly the
prime minister is responsible for the
joint intelligence committee and the
assessment it makes is that where the
responsibility lies with the prime
minister well actually you'll recall
that after the chilcot inquiry in the uh
second iraq war uh the jric was there to
give an independent assessment of
intelligence precisely to avoid
politicize uh politicization
but ultimately you have the jig giving
its assessment
and you then have the military and the
diplomatic assessment that's layered on
top of that
it was a collective assessment through
the jig
it was a collective assessment through
the jig that
you were referring to it wasn't a
particularly military assessment is that
correct well uh the the jig is there to
provide
the information if you like the rule
intelligence is distilled down and then
that is backed up by the military
assessment for example things like
intent although frankly
it's a cross-cutting issue and
my point is this the central assessment
that we were operating to um and it was
certainly backed up by both the jic
and the military is that the likely most
likely the central proposition
was that given the true withdrawal by
the end of
august you would see a steady
deterioration from that point
and that it was unlikely kabul would
fall
this year
that was the central assessment and of
course with all the usual caveats that
you will be familiar with that doesn't
mean we didn't do contingency planning
or game out or test the other
propositions and just to be clear that's
something that was widely shared that
view amongst nato allies
just come straight on to that
you clearly are responsible for
overseeing two of our intelligence
agencies did their intelligence differ
without revealing what it was of course
did their intelligence differ from that
assessment i i'm certainly not going to
go into the details of raw intelligence
the whole point of the jig is to distill
and provide an objective rounded
assessment
and i think that's quite right
i think they think they did their job
the um
very professional so may i just ask your
principal risk report of the 22nd of
july 2021 read
on afghanistan peace talks are stalled
and u.s nato withdrawal is resulting in
rapid taliban advances this could lead
to fall of cities collapse of security
forces taliban return to power mass
displacement and significant
humanitarian need the embassy may need
to close if security deteriorates this
was on the 22nd of july how did your
actions change after that report sorry
the the source of that it's your
principal risk report yeah well as i
said of course we are very mindful of
that so as i said um if you look at um
high-risk embassies
from the point of view of the embassy
safety as opposed to the evacuation i
think those two things are important to
distinguish we have a standard
evacuation process for high-risk
embassies like kabul
obviously that's reviewed
and has to evolve and adapt to the
conditions which is
why you're
uh what you said is uh timeline of
course we keep it under review as i said
the central assessment remained uh until
uh
late that the deterioration would be uh
uh
incremental
and the planning for military withdrawal
obviously began in april
but the contingency
planning
was also there
for a more
rapid deterioration and you can see that
in the run-up to the g7
summit in june one of my focuses was as
we anticipated the potential shift from
the embassy in the green zone to the
airport and the taipan area was making
sure that the so-called enablers things
like evacuation capacity
the
medical
capacity the security at the airport was
in place
and we did all of that to make sure that
we could shift from the green zone as we
did to the airport in the 13th to 14th
um that's also why just to give you a
sense we speeded up the relocation of
former afghan staff under the out
program we did that from april onwards
so why we changed our travel advice in
april it's why the the number of uk
staff at the kabul embassy was drawn
down from 115 to 75 in may um and uh
so so whilst the central assessment was
the one i described doesn't mean we
weren't doing contingency planning or
scotland all assessments can i then ask
on the contingency plan very
specifically when did you last update
the neo for afghanistan when did we last
update that the non-competent evacuation
operation order for afghanistan
i'd have to check that but i can tell
you
that we started planning in june
for the contingency of a of a an
evacuation um and therefore a drawdown
full drawdown of the embassy
notwithstanding the central assessment
still remained
and of course the timing on all of this
was very much synchronized with what our
fellow nato allies were doing so as well
as the domestic process we were docking
in and checking and sense checking with
our nato allies about
how they saw things running
and
as part of that presumably you knew how
many british citizens were roughly or
entitled people were roughly going to be
requiring your services
i'm not sure that is true because of the
combination
particularly in afghanistan
of un of not just documented passport
nationals who maybe they're traveling
seeing friends backpacking whatever it
may be but also and this was one of the
great challenges um the
incidents of large families some of whom
were documented mononationals dual
nationals perhaps but nonetheless
documented others who had a less clear
status either because of their
eligibility or because of the lack of
documentation so actually that's one of
the reasons why it's been difficult to
give a definitive uh account of the
number i understand that in that case
may i ask um because your assessment of
the number of people requiring
evacuation went from about 5 000 to
about 15 000 who were evacuated
could you tell me why you are confident
of your numbers of those remaining in
afghanistan now
we're not confident with any precision
at all
because for two reasons
no i don't i don't think that we think
that uh in terms of nationals uh we're
into the hundreds uh
possibly the mid to low hundreds but
again it depends on eligibility which of
course is one of the things that has
been a challenge what i would say this
is we got broadly um uh
let me check the numbers so i give you
exactly um the the right figure we've
got um
something like an estimate of 500 out
between
april
and
the 15th
of august
and in terms of british nationals a
further roughly 7 000 out during the
period between the 15th and the 29th of
august
alicia was a quick question about
coalition building um so in terms of a
coalition to prevent this outcome a
coalition to see the uk remain with our
allies
what went so horribly wrong that only
turkey was willing to stand by the uk
and what could we have done to build a
better coalition to work with partners
to build a coalition without the us so i
think this is one of the really
important things to nail
um and one of the i've said all along i
was very keen that the foreign office
had a reality check about some of the
optimism bias including the optimism
bias for example that the americans
would change their mind if you look at
the february 2020 decision by the
previous administration and then you
follow what was happening in the
presidential election campaign and then
you followed what the signs were indeed
then the decision
by the incoming biden administration i
think one of the things i would say is
there was some wishful thinking uh in
some quarters internationally
that
the biden administration would change or
dramatically alter and i always thought
that and i think this is correct and
accurate and i discussed this with karen
pierce that the election campaign had
baked in a broad not exact consensus
about some finality to this
forgiveness i think with biden there was
no question that he was going to leave
he's wanted to do that for 20 years uh
he's always been pushing obama to leave
that has been biden's sole purpose of
foreign policy to get afghanistan why
couldn't we convince germany france in a
way any of our other other allies
essentially to form a new coalition on
the ground making up the numbers the
americans were going to take out i think
if you look at the military capacity
proportionately that the u.s put in and
therefore the shortfall i don't think
there was any will or appetite and again
um don't be wrongly so you're right we
checked the defense secretaries talked
about this it was very clear
come the nato summit
that i attended
in the foreign minister's meetings that
partners would stick to the maxim that
nato went in together they would adapt
the mission together as they did in 2014
and they would exit together so if i'm
honest with you unless i don't think
there was any viable
alternative coalition once the us
decision had been taken and again i
think uh
there needed to be some reality about
that in the public discourse because it
was clear to me uh there were not going
to be anyone that could backfill for the
capacity that the u.s provided and the
u.s were unlikely to shift the the
parameters beyond a few months and that
is exactly what happened
immediately with given that's the case
and given that you foresaw this why is
it that the french evacuated everybody
they had and who was dependent on them
and we were scrabbling around
with a huge press of crowds at the
airport and sadly have left a lot of
people behind
well i'm afraid the the analogy uh i
don't think it runs i don't i think
you're i don't think you're comparing uh
like for like um but we uh
we got out uh 15 over 15 000 but in the
last two weeks of august um and of
course if you look back to april uh when
we started to advise we gave the travel
advice that people should leave we
expedited the arab
set up an expertise arab
programme the reality was many afghans
so between those two periods 2500 i
think broadly um uh left including arab
and british nationals but the reality
was given the uh scale of numbers that
we have uh and this and the size of our
um
the nature of our population not just
the size of it and there are lots of
people like uh who were taken so by
surprise by the scale and the pace of
the taliban advance and therefore they
only came relatively late on so we were
doing everything we could and we got
500 out but the lion's share um as you
as you would know came with the search
for the door once it was evident that
kabul was likely to fall
bob you wanted to come on quickly
foreign secretary just for clarity sake
you said in the past a couple of days
that everyone was caught by surprise
um and that the intelligence was clearly
wrong
just in simple terms why was that is it
because we were being led by an over
optimistic assessment from the u.s is
that a collective failure in the part of
the uk was the information different
from the military as opposed to the
diplomatic channels why did we get it so
badly wrong
um i think there's a whole range of
assumptions that um
one the optimism bias about what the u.s
might or might not do um
two i think around the intent of the
taliban
i always cautioned
that i thought the taliban
were
unlikely once the u.s decision to
withdraw was clear to engage
in particular meaningful
dialogue around a more inclusive
government
and
and seized the opportunity to take
control that relates to intent with much
bigger question whether they have the
capacity to back up that intent and i
think in fairness that is something
which uh collectively cross-allies
clearly the assessment that they
would not be able to advance to that
speed was not correct
and we'll need to look and assess about
why that's the case
today as to why and where you think and
this is about learning for the future
not just about finding scapegoats about
where that failure came from are you
talking about optimism bias were there
other factors do you think they're
irrelevant
well i want to be respectful i've you
know tested i mean i've tested uh the
assessments and the evidence and as i
said partly because the history of the
foreign office being accused of being
itself up to having an optimism by us i
wanted us to do the opposite um but
ultimately we've got a very rigorous
process and we'll have to look at how
the assessments got wrong i would offer
one reflection and it's no more than
that i think when you've been in a
country like afghanistan for 20 years
and all the blood sweat and tears and
toil and all the sacrifice maybe people
around this committee will know exactly
what that means
i think there is a sense a desire
absolute determination to make it uh
work to make things better and
and to believe that you can uh complete
the the task um i think there's a
question at what point and this goes
back to 2001 right the way through not
an attempt to take responsibility of the
last period in which this government's
been in but at what point do we really
have clearly identified the military
objectives the means to achieve them and
a clear and coherent exit strategy i
think in fairness that is something that
was much debated at the time and in 2014
at the end of combat operations but i
think there does need to be a
consideration of how difficult when
you're in a conflict for 20 years
emotionally if not not not anything else
it is to extract yourself and because of
that despite that plans you were still
caught slightly on the hot because of
the intelligence failure despite the
best laid plans is that fair
look the the we always try and i think
as politicians certainly as ministers um
and i'm sure across whitehall we try and
uh uh aim out for the for these things
but look you asked me for reflection
actually i think uh we've got a very
professional uh way of approaching these
things but when they're wrong and we've
seen economic forecasts that are wrong
this is obviously a different order of
things but you need to look at how you
correct that
comment about exit plans what's the
united states access plan from south
korea
i don't know okay but you know in in
fairness
i don't think
that's a commensurable commitment albeit
it's a very important one having been up
to the demilitarized uh zone uh and
spit spoken to the commanders and looked
across uh the border i i don't think we
see them
in harm's way
certainly for many years in the way that
they've actively been in harm's way in
afghanistan because 20 years after the
end of the korean war the united states
still had thousands of troops in what
was then a vicious military dictatorship
with an economy uh smaller than
afghanistan's and a broken state
but despite that they endured and pushed
through but maybe that's another
question chris
so as i understand it and you'll correct
me i'm sure if i'm wrong and there was a
majority intelligence view which was
that um the afghan forces would manage
to hold on
indefinitely
or certainly for some period
and then there was a minority view
which for which you prepared a
contingency plan that you were but you
started in june
and most of your eggs were in the
majority view basket and you had a few
eggs in the minority view which was that
you might have to have a contingency is
that right
i wouldn't put it quite like that
there's not it's not a question of the
minority report you have a central
assessment and you of course uh uh you
have a
worst case scenarios which you
contingency plan for as well i think
that's quite right
the prime minister said in the house of
commons on the 18th of august what is
not true is to say that the uk
government were unprepared or did not
foresee this i.e the collapse of kabul
and the afghan forces because it was
certainly part of our planning
and i suppose then the charge is
that you just didn't put enough effort
into the contingency planning isn't it
no i think he he's rightly identifying
um
that
we had planned uh let me you know again
we uh we your plan this is what you
planned
it's why we um focused in the run-up to
the june g7 summit about the shift the
potential shift from the green zone to
the airport it's why we speeded up the
relocation of former afghan staff under
the arap program from april onwards
relocating nearly 2000 during that
period that's why we changed our travel
advice uh in april well let me just come
together and that's why sorry just to
complete the picture it's why we reduced
the number of uk staff at the kabul
embassy in may uh
from 115 to 75. so but you i mean and
that's the nature of dealing catering
with a risk-based assessment you have a
central proposition but you're also
mindful of dealing with the worst-case
scenario even if it's
not regarded as likely
but let me just take you through some
dates
the u.s had left the two main air bases
in kandahar and bagram by the 2nd of
july
on the 8th of july several mps in the
house of commons told the prime minister
and that the taliban were likely to take
large parts of the country
on the 14th of july the taliban had
seized all the major border crossings
into tajikistan iran and pakistan
on the 21st of july the u.s said that
the taliban had seized half the country
but we only you only change the travel
advice for british nationals going to
afghanistan on the 6th of august
that's not quite true um in april we
changed our travel advice to advise
british nationals to consider leaving
afghanistan we changed it again to make
it even more stringent in august
we started in june notwithstanding the
central assessment the
uh
the contingency plans for a military-led
evacuation which is the big shift and
it's worth just saying
that commercial flights were still
running uh
up until the 14th of august even after
we changed the travel of ice on the 6th
of august that you cited
on the 11th of august the u.s said that
the taliban were likely to seize the
whole country it was just a question of
how long it was going to take
were you already on holiday
so by the way the the
that is part of the central assessment
that i described uh that we thought that
they would seize uh or i mean there are
basically a variety of scenarios between
taliban takeover and civil war but the
most likely the central assessment was
that it would be a taliban consolidation
of power but that it would take
place in the months following the
evacuation and that
that kabul would not fall before the end
of the year
you didn't ask answer mike the second
question were you already on holiday
uh
a full statement on my holiday i've said
that i wouldn't have gone uh um
away with the benefit of hindsight which
is uh the luxury of just coming
i'm not going to start chris adding to
frankly the the
fishing expedition uh beyond the facts
that i've articulated in a fulsome
statement and having answered questions
uh continuously about that i would just
make the broader point
i'm sorry mr raab
the problem here is that
of course it's perfectly legitimate for
ministers to go on holiday everybody has
that right
and i would argue it's an important part
of people being fresh enough to be able
to do their job properly the difficulty
for us is
that the prime minister was on holiday
and the deputy prime minister yourself
was on holiday and as i understand it
the permanent undersecretary was on hold
all three at the same time
when
british nationals were at risk
many people thousands of people by our
own estimation who stood by us in a
difficult time in afghanistan were in
peril of their lives
and there was still not a proper um
crisis center up in place do you not see
that it's important for british people
to understand why you thought it was
right to go on holiday no sorry i'm
afraid i don't
agree with that analysis of course i've
been clear with the benefit of hindsight
i wouldn't have gone away at all and
the
the charge in relation to officials i
think is particularly unwarranted
because we always make sure that we have
the right cover in place the permit
secretary did an excellent job
and quite right given
all of the ir the sr the merger that he
should
take some leave
in terms of
um
my own situation i just say this i'm
traveling today
a modern foreign secretary has to have
the ability given those wide range of
issues that will constantly bubble up
possibly to crisis point to be able to
deal act work
from
abroad i engaged in all of the cobra
meetings
i engaged and directed the emergency
response team
directly uh and
uh i was engaged with international
partners so the uh
the the and the truth is chris judge us
by the results because between the uh
and the end of august we delivered over
15 000 people out of the country which i
think is the uh certainly the most
challenging uh
evacuation of its kind in living memory
on results can you tell us how many
people you think
both uk nationals and their families and
then the people who might qualify um
because they worked for uk forces and
then thirdly they're extremely
vulnerable what do you think what is
your best estimate of those numbers and
i fully accept that you're not going to
be able to give
you know there's three categories you're
right um in terms of nationals we got
through the overwhelming majority of
nationals that we could verify
eligibility
numbers sorry
i've given you the number that we you
know but you also answered questions you
said you weren't confident of the
numbers so i'm just wondering so i'm not
confident in the numbers remaining but
we think that they would be in the low
hundreds why below hundreds do you mean
110 sort of area or do you mean 200 300
400. they will be in the low hundreds um
but i i don't i'm very reticent about
giving a firm figure precisely because
we don't know one of the reasons
sounds that it could be 400 or it could
be 105 110 115
and and if i could give you any more
precision chris i would but let me just
between 100 and 500 so let me explain uk
nationals so let me explain why it's
difficult because we got most of the uh
if not all of the mono nationals who are
documented who wanted to leave out and
we're left with
some
it has to be said a significant
proportion client who could not
establish their nationality but also a
category of more complex cases
particularly with significant wider
families where one or other may have
documented nationality or can
demonstrate it others and the concentric
circles of immediacy of their dependence
couldn't and that's why it's difficult
in relation to arab i think the mod have
uh and this defense secretary have put
an assessment out and then you asked
about the third category the more
vulnerable i mean
i think their number they're giving is
between 150 and 250.
the mod yeah well i i defer to the
defense secretary on the on the airplane
this is a major problem it seems to me
about the whole way the government's
approached this which is that you've had
three separate channels
every mp
every mp has had individuals coming to
their constituency surgeries or ringing
them up or emailing them
desperate about family members in
afghanistan some of them uk nationals
some of them who might qualify under
arab and some of them who might qualify
under the sort of special cases very
vulnerable people um system
but nobody knows why is there no triage
system i have three different
departments where you can't even speak
on behalf of the mod on how many people
under arab are still outstanding there's
two different things the arab program
was set up by the mod in the home office
it's right that they confirmed those
figures you're right to refer to three
different categories of case we have one
of the reasons uh
the um
uh the the
uh
fco was criticized the emergency center
was because precisely because we were
seeking to triage uh the three types of
case the reason there's three types of
cases there's three grounds for
eligibility to come to this country one
is you're a british national that
requires evidence of something very well
you're sure
i agree
sorry but for that matter lots of
families might have somebody in all
three categories which is why a single
system would surely be much far more
effective well no because the criteria
the threshold and the evidence for what
counts as nationality is very different
from the arab scheme and the criteria
that we work through and
and is a risk-based uh set of criteria
for those that worked for us and shown
loyalty to us and this and the third
category is a
sec essentially um based on
international law and is again a
vulnerability a
a an asylum related set of criteria
those are all three different thresholds
see why that might seem
and to the people who are experiencing
it like the left hand not knowing what
the right hand is doing and
departmentalize as writ large can i can
i just are people being treated as
numbers rather than
humans i think
we would be
remiss if we weren't prioritizing and
this is a form of prioritizing according
to the three categories that matter most
british nationals of course we must do
everything for them and their dependents
secondly those that work for us and we
need to have a definition of that and
thirdly because we've announced that we
will be taking under the resettlement
scheme 5000 this year leading up to a
total of twenty thousand uh and those
will be based on objective independent
international related criteria for those
at a risk of persecution it is precisely
because we need to as well as uh
demonstrate the huge compassion that we
as a country are doing but also have
criteria to make sure that those that we
want to come come rather than just
opening the door and saying actually
we're going to
have an unstructured approach to this
which if i took what you're saying to
its logical conclusion i think would
undermine public confidence in the
system i think we're doing everything we
can and the proof is in the 17 000 that
since april we have secured safe passage
back to the uk and i'm very happy to
talk through
those numbers and the cases and the
achieving scholars and the female judges
and the journalists that we have taken
to safety
we know
obviously that there's a significant
number of people who have not got out i
think you're accepting that yes
in the several thousands any number that
we haven't got out uh because of the uh
evacuation and the uh the situation uh
is is is is too many yeah so i i
understand the point you're making but
basically there's a significant number
have you put a number on that of how
many people you think
um
we have left behind
well it's the same you're answering
asking the same question a different way
and i just said i can't give you a
definitive and by the way the other
thing is okay but it's just what the
prime minister said that the
overwhelming majority
of the people who um
owed us
who stood by in us in other words people
who work for us the overwhelming
majority of them are out but if you're
not confident of the numbers how can the
prime minister possibly know whether the
overwhelming majority are out or not i'm
not confident with precision to be able
to give you a set number but i am
confident that the prime minister's
right that we've got the overwhelming
number out what our focus on is now
is how given the facts on the ground we
get as many people uh to safety uh in a
structured way um and in a in a way that
doesn't put them in
and i think one of the reasons that lots
of mps are troubled by this is because
we had nigel adams before us last year
and when we had to evacuate an awful lot
of people because of kovid from all
sorts of different places around the
world and it just feels as if the
foreign office hasn't learned anything
from that can i address that square on
yeah i looked very carefully and i take
this committee very seriously uh and
your july 2020 report uh from the
repatriation effort on covid we took
very seriously by the way the consular
team did an incredible job during the
covert crisis getting people back home
and we worked night and day we learned a
lot on things like the call center we
learned a lot on the scalability
your committee uh chris and mr chen
made a number of points about the
ability to scale up quickly for example
as a result we established a contingency
planning team
within the crisis management department
and uh
we established the crisis response to
the afghanistan situation on the 11th of
august it doubled in size and scale of
civilian staff from 70 on day 1 to 146
on day 3 again to 358 on day six 510 on
day nine and uh hit a peak of 581 on day
11.
you you also talked about that's all in
the uk yes so again yes staff are all in
the crisis response
you also talked about tom the shifting
the communication pattern you felt it
was too passive and it wasn't active uh
enough particularly on social media so
as a result of that we put in place of
structures to
provide
more proactive advice including
outsourcing to a call handling provider
for immediate support for our contact
center we had a team of 45 consular
staff from around the seo network
deployed to take calls alongside our
contact center
we had an extra 35 staff from the hmrc
the other one that i thought was
important you said there was an over
reliance on commercial flights by the
way i personally think you're wrong
about that in relation to covid i think
it was right to try and get
the huge number we did back on
commercial flights to free up the spaces
on the charters but in any event even if
i disagreed i looked at your
recommendations very carefully so as a
result we now have a contract with ctm
and are using it for our charter flights
or did use it for our charter flights
and that allowed us to get planes
arranged quickly departing within two
days the beginning of operations so feel
free to criticize but first of all we
did learn the lessons from the point at
which you spoke to nigel and we did take
the recommendations of this committee
very seriously
i mean
i've just got one more question which is
um
the prime minister's well i texted you
with more details of another case today
a british national who's in afghanistan
and i i don't want i'm not going to go
into the individual issues
um
i know he's spoken very passionately on
television about how what desperate
situation he's in and every mp will have
had cases like this
and we've all been running around trying
to find different means of getting
people out including lots of people on
this committee and we are grateful to um
you personally and uh and to everybody
in the foreign office and who's been
involved in all of this but what we're
now really anxious about is the people
who are left
and the prime minister said that he was
going to move heaven and earth
um to get them out
what advice would you be giving to
people now
for instance members of the hosara
community who are effectively facing a
genocide
and self-declared by the taliban in
afghanistan
to individuals who work for us who are
still stuck there british nationals who
are still stuck there what's the advice
go to the border
so can i can i walk you through where we
are with the third country planning
because i think it's more than just give
x or y uh advice and by the way can i
also say that in terms of special cases
so-called special cases we did get out
58 which evening scholars and their
dependents 287 journalists 68 65 women's
rights activists um 11 members of the
of government 42 law enforcement uh
officials 37 extremely vulnerable
individuals nine judges um
and others besides in terms of the third
country planning uh there are a number
of stages but first we need to be able
to secure safe passage
out of afghanistan at least until that
point at which kabul airport is up and
running at which case
things will change materially
we have sought and secured direct
assurances
that we can do that for our nationals
and indeed the people that worked for us
and you would have noticed that we
led the way with france and the u.s
to secure a u.n security council
resolution requiring it now of course
that gold ensures national communities
leverage on the taliban to try and
exercise pressure so that's the first
thing secondly we've identified the
countries most likely
to be the port of call or destination
for those leaving
there's a whole range of them in between
myself and lord ahmed we've spoken to
all of the foreign ministers to be clear
that they will be
in the right circumstances allowed
through
third
we focused on the documents required uh
to allow people to cross that border
into the third country whether it's a
note of a ballot or some other means of
our
ambassador or high commissioner
informing the border authorities this
individual we will take
then um
we've and i just sent out they'll arrive
in the next 36 hours
a rapid deployment team of 15 people who
will service those
those areas where we expect
people will head for that will include
pakistan uzbekistan tajikistan and
others
fifth
we've obviously got to look very
carefully at the security checks uh in
relation to that and i'm working that
through the home sector in the home
office
in real time we spoke last night and
this morning as well on it
i'm going to the regime tonight
and
to test
the accessibility of these arrangements
and of course as you mentioned
haiko mass has been to uzbekistan but
we've got to keep those borders open but
i think part of that is giving those
third countries
arrangements that they can feel
confident in perhaps support as well and
then finally just to say on monday
uh the g7
turkey qatar the nato secretary general
had a meeting
of course which i joined about this
importance of keeping airports open for
third
countries
and this issue of safe passage so both
in terms of the granular arrangements
we're making but also the international
concerted action uh that's in place in
in terms of the answer your question
what we will get to you uh through
travel advice and otherwise is the sign
posting so that you can give that advice
and it will be directly there for
individuals from all of those different
countries including the one you
mentioned now just very briefly i know
you're going to go to the region clearly
this isn't the time to be making best
friends it would be great to have them
earlier is this your first trip to
pakistan
i've been to pakistan before as far as
secretary but no not as foreign
secretary the truth is uh
i was hoping to go but
kovid
has inhibited travel for quite a while
as you you'll understand indeed
uh
neil you oh sorry forgive me unless you
want to come in very briefly
you mentioned there were 510 foreign
office staffers in the uk
how many were on the ground because the
issue was not planes it was processing
uh the barren hotel was an extremely
vulnerable point before the terror
attack
i had families outside 36 hours 48 hours
an unconscious baby for two hours who
only got into baron hotel because
friends helped me get the military
outside the compound to drag that family
and get that girl on the saline drip how
many staff do we have on the ground and
why wasn't processing quicker because
that was the hold up
sorry lucy i want to answer your
question really fully i'm not clear when
you're talking now we clearly don't the
time of the processing in the last the
two weeks that we've all spent
desperately trying to get people out how
many foreign office staff were on the
ground processing
we peaked at 20
and of course just to be clear you
absolutely need the front-facing
staff but the the decision-making was
via the scdo
crisis response team because you could
get the decision-makers at the senior
level there and you could integrate them
in terms of the scgo consular people the
border force people the uk these people
and also the military planners i'm very
happy to take you through the
scalability of what we did given
the taliban advance on kabul and i'm
happy to answer questions on what we did
in relation to the explosion but um we
we peaked at 20 plus there were uh 13
border force staff
but the the
the the principal issue
at all material times i would say
between the 4 14 15 and the end of
august has been
the issue of stability and security
around the airport so we could bolster
that capacity i do think that some of
the nonsense that i've read in the
papers if i may say
the suggestions that we should have been
putting people uh in
uh when the airport was not secure when
the paris and the american forces had
not secured that airport when we just
had an isis k attack uh literally a
stone's throw from the uh the barons
hotel processing center i do find rather
irresponsible but we had incredibly
courageous bunch of mod home office and
seo civilian staff and i feel uh i hope
you don't mind saying quite protective
about some of the nonsense that's been
said they put themselves under
conditions of incredible pressure and
a measure of risk to themselves that
many of their critics i'm afraid have
not i can speak to the whole committee
and say that the gratitude that we have
civilians and soldiers who served our
country with enormous dignity and
courage in afghanistan is not something
that this committee would run away from
we are on the contrary hugely proud of
them and extremely grateful for this i
was also talking tom about the civilian
staff i said civilian stuff as well
forgive them i didn't see that
so i was a member of the rapid
deployment in the foreign office you are
trained specifically to do neos you are
trained to be in the most vulnerable
collapsing crisis
my question is we didn't send out rdt
teams until the 17th of august is that
correct
let me walk you through the
the details of that
the decision to withdraw
fcods scdo staff uh on the 13th was on
the 13th of august um we of course the
ambassador remained by the way was he
instructed to remain or did he choose to
remain
no no
there's no question of telling him to do
something that he uh was not able to do
i and i of course um uh talked it
through them in a professional way no
one has been more courageous um uh with
the exception of the forces on the
ground uh than laurie bristow in in
terms of the civilian presence um the by
the way the the the decision was based
on a military assessment of risk to be
absolutely clear about this the decision
to take some of our uh the lion's share
frankly of our
crisis response team on the ground the
civilian element to dubai was based on a
military assessment risk and indeed
civilian
personnel from the mod left on the same
flight
the ambassador remained
the scdo staff were only taken to dubai
so we could get back as they did in the
17th of august
when we went back in just to be clear
and i'm not pointing uh
fingers but the border force staff
didn't arrive until later that week but
that's because we were all operating to
the same assessment of military risk on
the ground and as you all know i think
it is right when there's a risk to life
william to defer to that but if the rdt
team deploying the 17th of august why
was it not considered safe for them to
go before that point because they are
you constantly have a full rdt team on
deployment ready to go within an hour's
notice at all times so we got them back
in on the 17th
so that you know there was a four day
period and the truth is that
this the paris and the u.s forces had
not arrived in full and secured that
airport until then and we got them back
in um on the ground in the 17th they
were bolstered again to a peak of 20
plus 13 border force staff in addition
we had this a further rdt of seven in
dubai
and
as we've already gone through over 200
staff at the scdo crisis centre working
24 7 to coordinate the response um if
the question is yet is were they somehow
reticent uh no there's no question that
they were reticent and and there was no
the only logistical issue
lots of logistical issues um the
principal logistical issue was the
safety of that airport for them to be
able to do the job and indeed as you
know in the processing center you're
asking people to come forward in the
processing center as we've dis as you
have seen from the footage around the
terrorist attack was outside the airport
so on top of securing the airport we
also needed to know that the processing
center at barron's court was safe i
cannot put people into harm's way at
risk of losing their life
we do it with soldiers and they
their heroism is
rightly rounded but with civilian staff
we have to take the assessment of
military risk on the ground and that is
what quite professionally we did i think
that's the crux the question we all
agree it was vulnerable the whole point
is therefore getting afghans and british
nationals into baron hotel at speed
which is what wasn't happening that was
the issue that's where the risk but it
wasn't safe
it wasn't secure forgive me i'm going to
move on because neil call wants to come
in
and safety there were 18 months to
prepare prepare for evacuation and
you've just said today that in the last
six months you had 40 meetings about
evacuating the high-risk situation and
yet we ended up with a position where
three different government departments
around three different helplines and
hotlines which were not being answered
and your department had an afghan
special cases email address that wasn't
even been opened in life and death cases
who is responsible for that chaos on the
ground well i don't accept that
categorization i'm happy to go over any
of those issues uh in terms of the
emails uh or anything else please do the
the react well i can i can address the
email issue but
first of all the reality is we
secured uh over 15 000 people out okay
okay you've said that and you want to be
applauded for those you've gone out but
there were nine thousand estimated left
behind who is taking responsibility for
helplines and the email address in your
department not even being opened
so the the issue as you had a search for
the door is that you have a search of uh
emails including uh late emails and and
requests like that but let me just
explain the situation for you for female
just
purely for transparency we've got the
three types of cases they
you know
melding them all in together frankly and
countries that didn't use three
different cases
you've got you're not answering the
question you're going back to the
question from
but but other countries use one process
south korea france other examples
they've got people out other countries
and other examples in lebanon in 2006
were used
as
all countries were focused in one way or
another on evacuating based on
nationality people that work for them
and other vulnerable cases particularly
those with an affinity towards them they
all face that that challenge and i don't
believe uh the that any of the countries
with the the types of cases particularly
family cases but others uh fed uh uh
better and i think those goals they're
reporting that they did and you can't
even tell us today how many people are
left behind abandoned by the uk company
after 20 years of service now that
includes and can you tell us today
whether the afghan guards from the
british embassy in kabul have been
evacuated or not they were held up due
to paperwork problems
well
um are they here
we we we wanted to get um some of those
embassy guards
but the buses arranged to collect them
to take them to the airport weren't
given permission to to enter um and that
is i'm afraid reflection of the
conditions on the ground we will of
course which comes back to the third
country uh uh arrangements they were
held up due to paperwork so so let's
let's stick with some of this because
the defense secretary let's stick with
the same issue because you can't say
whether they're here or not it sounds
like so so you're not answering the
question so allow me to move on the
defense secretary who i think is
credited by most is having worked his
solutions
through this crisis well you're not
answering the question 460 so let's move
on the defense secretary said it was not
good enough to leave details of uk
linked afghans in the british embassy as
was reported in the times and do you
agree with that assessment and who is
taking responsibility for that security
and safety risk for those nationals so
let me talk you through the this is the
documentation
the first thing to say in relation to uh
the uh situation is of course uh it is
regrettable uh it reflects i think it's
fair to say the pressure on the ground
we had a five-day uh uh scheduled uh
approach for closure of the embassy and
it got caught
forward because of the situation on the
ground i have nonetheless
um asked for uh a um a full uh review of
as to what happened to make sure we can
learn the lessons but just to be clear
we uh
there's the times that um
broke this story or revealed this story
they shared the names with us we moved
rapidly to evacuate the three families
from kabul within 24 hours and all of
those whose names the times passed to us
uh and he worked for us and now in the
uk so that's good and they but they
should never have been at risk so
the general the lord dana has said as a
former chief of staff that you were
asleep at the helm so can i just ask do
you owe those afghan nationals and those
british troops who have flown into a
more dangerous situation late an apology
for the circumstances that they have
faced i think we owe them every effort
to
get the those out that we did over 17
000 since april and now to focus on the
new reality in afghanistan with the
arrangements that we're working on at
speed which is why i'm going to the
region shortly with our international
partners which is what i've been doing
all week to get
those that remain out as swiftly as
safely and as responsibly as possible no
apology has been heard so can answer do
you own the prime minister an apology
because i believe you promised
that the portrait of her majesty would
not be left in the british
embassy so what went so badly wrong and
is our queen and our country less safe
as a result of the taliban takeover
i was the first i have to say that i've
heard reported that the portrait of the
queen was left in the embassy my
understanding was that uh that was
destroyed you saying that it wasn't
with the fourth of the queen right well
we we had a very clear in fact i i
talked through with the team the um
the
the policy for destroying
not just documents but anything relating
to hmg it's not clear to me when that
came from outside or inside the embassy
clearly we were conscious of the
attempted propaganda coup around um uh
taliban taking over in the season
and what have you the reality is we
haven't seen an attack from afghanistan
terrorist attack on the west uh in 20
years and what we've now got to focus on
which our security council resolution
which uk is the forefront driving
forward uh focuses on is making sure
that we continue to exercise the maximum
leverage on the taliban we possibly can
it's worth also saying that the isis k
attack uh on abbey gate uh also appears
to have been targeted at taliban as well
as u.s and others
very briefly alicia um under what
circumstances will the uk be recognized
the taliban and what sort of recognition
do you foresee and as part of that what
is your assessment of the relationship
between the taliban the faction we're
dealing with and
al-qaeda
well
first of all we do not recognize
governments generally
but i think it's also important not to
confer any legitimacy on the taliban at
the same time we do need to be able to
send clear and direct signals we've done
that
for some time by their political
commission which has been based in doha
we now have simon gas
the
prime minister's special envoy in the
region to ensure that we can do that and
we want to have as much continuity
in our diplomatic presence as possible
we want to be in a position when the
safety and security allows to have a
continuity diplomatic presence uh in
afghanistan but clearly that's not
possible right now and your last
question was al-qaeda and their their
relationship with the faction taliban
who seem to be in negotiations with well
i think i look i think there are all
sorts of tensions within the taliban and
uh even more acute uh factionism between
them and the groups and as i mentioned
before isis k appears to have been
targeting the taliban as well as others
at the abbey gate um
and so i i think uh first of all
the taliban has been clear
it's made these assurances publicly will
not give sakura or haven to terrorist
groups u.n security council resolution
back that up it's important because
although it was only acquiesced in by
china and russia it is the beginning of
the contours of a new set of parameters
which will exercise greater pressure and
hopefully maximum moderating leverage on
the taliban but look these are early
days and we need to set credible and
realistic tests of the taliban and
engage with them on the basis of whether
or not they follow through
sorry even as the u.n is debating that
we've had credible reports of biometric
data left behind in afghanistan being
used to target and murder former nds
staff so
forgive me if i'm doubtful as to the
level of leverage that we may
end up being able to achieve
um i know you shared doubts as well so i
won't go any further stuart you wanted
to come in and then i'll go to green
thank you chair and thanks for the
secretary for your time this afternoon
um have you been to afghanistan's
foreign secretary previously
no no
um
your own actions and leadership of
commander intent scrutiny i don't want
to go into all the holiday um
stuff but i do want to understand
how your own actions correspond with the
advance of the taliban
across the country who you spoke to when
you spoke to them
so
if we could go back to august 6th when
uh zarage the capital of the nimro's
province fell who did you speak to them
well look i'm very happy i've got a
whole call shoot here um but the the
reality was in terms of to give you the
the the the clear uh approach i was
taking
that at all of these points the most
critical thing was to be engaged with
our allies nato uh g7 regional allies to
try and uh assess and influence uh what
was going on on the ground and to plan
accordingly so as that happened on the
ground who did you talk to that day
i i would have to get back to you on the
specific dates and uh
yeah why don't you we'll do a mop up in
the usual way so if i was to go through
right now all of the
various days where more and more of the
country
has fallen to taliban rule right now
you wouldn't be able to tell me who you
talk to on what date because your own
actions have come under intense scrutiny
up to the point of calls for resignation
accusations of being missing
in action and i think it's really
important that we understand that as the
situation got worse and worse and worse
what the foreign secretary was doing and
who he was talking to beyond vague
uh and i don't doubt you were talking to
uh people but beyond vague lines such as
talking to g7 partners nato partners and
all the rest of it because you have a
very specific allegation lead to you
that even after the fall of kabul you
haven't even talked to the uk
ambassadors in the surrounding countries
for five days is that correct but look
so first of all when did you talk to the
sorry when you talked to them
you're making a bunch of assertions let
me let me give you i look the as i said
before the advice from the ambassadors
and they will often attend the uh the
calls or the meetings we have internally
with the foreign office crisis center is
distilled down so we have a single
complete holistic view
i was
engaged with the sedo crisis response
team including the director and director
general uh on the cobra meetings uh
including of course with with lori
and
frankly your point about nato fm's uh
the nato meetings the g7 meetings these
were critical i want to come back
the idea that i would ring up every uh
ambassador rather than taking a uh you
said you take the committee seriously
you must have known this question was
coming look i wouldn't presume to guess
what questions you may want to ask we
get telegrams in
updating us on events uh as everyone
that worked at the foreign office chris
will know we assess them very carefully
i don't need to pick up the phone to get
an assessment from the ground what i do
need to do is get a holistic picture
from the team who are getting all the
different advice and get the options and
assess what we do next on the 10th of
august a new border crossing opens up
for the taliban to iran
had you talked to the british ambassador
to iran at that point so so by the way
all of the military developments on the
ground of course i was updated on but
but principally i'm guessing you didn't
was the accusation that you hadn't
spoken spoken to ambassadors who serve
underused foreign secretary
for a long time as the situation got
worse and worse
you haven't spoken to her majesty's
government's representatives in those
neighbouring capitals no
that's nonsense because i so tell me
when you talk to them
what you're saying is not correct
because we constantly have the feedback
and the advice coming through the the
central response team uh ambassadors
will join those meetings as it's
relevant for example if there's a
particular issue we need to hear
directly from it's the same uh in the
copa meetings and the the the uh
the lion's share of my effort was
working with not just critical regional
partners like uh
turkey qatar but also what is the allied
position in response to this that those
discussions were happening within nato
with the g7 sure and within the other
areas um so can i just understand
because i i've listened carefully to
what you said in media interviews and
what else about the various calls you're
engaged in
as you wear on holiday and much like mr
bryant i think it's important that the
people do take holidays but it's also
important to know when to cut them short
again for the sake of transparency of
your own actions when did you go on
holiday what dates did you go on holiday
not interested in what you did there
what date did you go look i i made him
full date did you go on holiday
foreign i think your own personal
transparency is important what date did
you go on holiday i made a full
statement on it uh i will say it was
clear i should have did the statement
include the date that you left at all
material times
why can't you just answer this question
this is absolutely because look to be
honest with you i think it's a pretty
partisan political i i just want to know
when you to be clear
because i think it's important we can
map out you know as mr bryant correctly
said earlier we have uk personnel uk
civilians in harm's way
and i think it's important for us to
know what you were doing and where you
were doing it from when did you go on
holiday and enrollment i'm not looking
to beat you over this i just want to
know where you went
it seems uh when did you get hold of
with the facts
what i've said to you is i'm getting
nowhere on this in terms of nato
discussions now there was the defense
secretary has said that
as the us was leaving he had tried to
speak to other nato members to see if
there was
uh some kind of arrangement that could
be created to supplement the absence of
the us
what has not been clear
is when did you or the prime minister
speak to the nato general secretary
about that possibility oh i was in i
mean again i can come back to you with
the specific dates but
the nato from ministers meetings and in
constant bilateral and uh other nato
calls including with the secretary
general uh
and indeed from well before uh even
under the previous trump administration
we were having these conversations i
think the defense sector was absolutely
right to check this in the way um i
described to alicia but there was no
credible uh alternative alliance there
just wasn't any suggestions to the
country i'm afraid they're not born out
it was wrong so you're saying that was
fully explored
of course it was it and the reason was
and the secretary general said the nato
allies said it uh consistently nato went
into afghanistan together they adapted
the mission together from 2014 and they
would withdraw together and there were
very few meaningful departures from that
view
why did it take so long to convene the
g7
uh
why do you i don't accept that it did
it so the fall of kabul happens on the
15th g7 meets on the 24th
look everyone was dealing with the
immediate situation on the ground um we
had uh you're referring i think to the
leaders meeting is that correct
yes there was a g7 foreign minister
meeting before that
and are you happy are you content with
the outcome of the the leaders meeting
well we circulated a paper uh that has
received i think very widespread
support for setting out a range of
priorities safe passage so we've all got
a similar problem there's no country i
think that
certainly in the conversations i've had
that isn't wanting to make sure that we
can make sure that we can get any
remaining uk
citizens plus afghans at workforce and
other vulnerable
the the issue of counterterrorism
clearly important how do we exercise
maximum leverage over the taliban not to
give suckle safe haven to any terrorist
groups i think there's a whole question
around regional stability and the
humanitarian lifeline there's an issue
here will the
um
will the taliban as many say wish to
reach out to try and get access to
international financial institutions and
to aid in which case they will have to
pass certain tests one of them obviously
will be
a safe working environment within
afghanistan
for
un and humanitarian groups to operate
because there's no way uh we would sound
like you are we would give money to the
taliban well it's the first step as was
the u.n security council resolution but
we've got to face it
and that's
pretty weak as well is it not
i think it's in terms of the ambition
no i think no it's pretty remarkable uh
in these conditions in these
circumstances with all the tensions that
are well known uh among security council
members to get a security council
resolution uh which at least has been
acquiesced by russia and china in durong
the council as well but the key thing is
going to be broadening that out so you
have not just a p5 and security council
set of uh buy-in but you've also then
got some of the regional players the big
donors that we'll need given the
humanitarian system system but but the
one point i was going to make is that
the taliban has a choice here um it is
uh and people on its behalf are
professing that they want to pay the
different way um
they they will not want to see the gains
certainly not the economic and social
structure such as it is totally collapse
and therefore there is an opportunity to
test
how seriously they want to continue to
have lines and ties out to the
international community if they want aid
we'll have to see a safe operating
environment uh within afghanistan we
wouldn't give it to the taliban um and
there's a whole range of other arts
around human rights particularly
protecting women i suspect christ comes
all that i'm conscious of timing i know
that other colleagues want to go and i
just have one very last question uh
chair in terms of your own leadership in
your own actions
up until this point
did you ever at any point
consider or offer to resign
no i considered getting on with the job
of what has been a herculean
task of getting 17 000 people out and
now focusing on
getting out the remaining people that we
want to see out of our third countries
and helping to forge internationally
which the prime minister is leading on i
believe i'm confident
on all of those priorities that i've
mentioned
graham forgive me
thank you
we're in different political parties uh
foreign secretary i i've no doubt uh
that you want to do the best for the
people who need to
uh get out of afghanistan i have no
doubt about that at all but on the
surface this looks like a a failure of
planning on on a grand scale
people are at risk some people who've
died probably we don't know about
yet and all i've heard you
say
is that you wish you'd come back from
holiday earlier
are there any other regrets that you
have
and anything you wish
that in policy terms or you yourself had
done differently to be more effective in
rescuing and and saving people well
first of all and that's not all i said
um i i have said in the benefit findings
i would have come back but i've also
talked through what we achieved um not
just for british nationals not just for
uh the afghans that work for us but for
the judges the women's rights defenders
the journalists i've also talked through
the next phase and how we need to
reinforce
all those efforts to get people out of
our third countries whilst kabul airport
is not operational
we'll always continue to learn i mean
i've read through three examples where i
post
the covid repatriation effort you and
your committee made a series of response
uh recommendations and we we embraced
them you know i came to this committee
uh readily when uh the chair suggested
that they wanted to hold the meeting
today i would suggest um it was
originally scheduled for an hour and i
need to to leave but i would suggest
giving the questions we we go on for
another half an hour and i hope that
demonstrates the committee how i take
the scrutiny uh very seriously and also
i think it is a part of ensuring that my
department myself can be as on our game
as possible but can i just say i think
uh there's been a little bit of breezing
over some of the operational challenges
uh given the rapid fall uh beyond the
expectation of kabul and what that
really meant on the ground what it meant
for afghans whether they were willing to
get to the airport whether we can get
our nationals to the airport not just
because of the logistical obstacles but
because of fear and the
the
the the anxiety um we were dealing with
all of that and i and i would still
stand by the fact that not just the
military but the civilian mod home
office studio staff have pulled off a
quite remarkable evacuation of people
greater in challenge and scale than
anything that's certainly in living
memory but but of course we'll continue
to learn all of those lessons
of course
i wouldn't deny i don't think any member
of the committee would uh deny
that everybody involved in the
operations on the ground were a risk and
it was extremely operationally uh
difficult what i was trying to ascertain
uh for the future and to understand what
has happened
whether you believe anything could you
could have done anything better or the
foreign office uh could have done
anything better
for instance it has been reported in the
press
as the department's thwarted efforts to
set up overland escape routes to the
surrounding countries of afghanistan
over quite a long
period in the run-up
to august that's been reported you can
tell us if it's true or not but i'm
interested because you you must have in
the privacy of the foreign office
thought we could have done that better
we should have done that with all the
difficulties and i think this committee
would be interested in in those views of
the experience of course graham and it's
a fair challenge on the first point it's
actually nonsense to say that the fcdo
thoughted attempts to create
lines out of the country the reality is
of course a lot of those third countries
are very apprehensive and what they need
to know is that we're going to support
them
by
having a workable system get our
nationals out otherwise you have to see
what happens has happened with
uzbekistan which is the border goes up
in terms of my own position if uh in
fairness i don't have a lot of time to
sit back and muse and mull
but but of course i'm always open to
learning lessons from the future i think
we need to get beyond the
stage of the crisis that we were out
with the evacuation
and
draw in all of that experience and look
at it with a calm and sober
reflection but of course i'll do that i
think any responsible
minister frankly anyone in any other
walk of life will do that looking at
various things in in the round
are you content that the shift patterns
the rotors the effort that was put in
the uk not just in afghanistan but in
the crisis center in the uk matched the
requirement of the operation
yes i mean and we looked at it and i
looked at it on a number of occasions to
make sure and i spoke to uh the director
general the permanent secretary to make
sure do we need extra resource you know
i can
uh
you know look at
the the various points that
that i did that and come back to you um
but but we were all i was constantly
thinking is there more we can do but the
real challenge in a narrow window was
the safety and security of kabul airport
it would have had an extra week sorry
forgive me i accept all of the couple
points i don't wish to go it's just
we're going to have to look at the
crisis center question again as you know
of course i'm sure you will be as well
and i'm just i'm just asking right now
are you content that you were doing the
24 7 shift seven days a week in london
that were being done in kabul are there
any areas of the rotor that you would
say needs to be augmented with people
working weekends all this sort of i'm
sure you you'll already be thinking
about it
well look we were running a three shift
24 7 operation since the 15th
we had partners across government
embedded
into the structure including seven from
the home office and the board of four
six from uh hm passport office 100 from
mod
of course i want to
glean the lessons and readily embrace
the opportunities
we're in
an even better uh position next time
around god forbid anything like this
happens again but we do that and i think
the evidence for that tom is how we
responded after what i also think was a
very impressive repatriation effect on
coving we still looked at ourselves in
the mirror asked ourselves all of those
difficult questions and got better and
you can see it indeed foreign i
appreciate your points i'm i i get the
lessons learned i'm going to come to two
very quick ones if i made bob really
briefly yes just quicken you said that
once the the u.s pulled out
a a nato operation without the us was a
non-starter was that due to either lack
of political will by other nato
countries was it due to lack of funding
or desire to fund or are we talking
about technical capacity and capability
because that seems to be an important
question for the future are we always
going to be dependent on the us for
deployment or can you do forward
deployment without the us so what was
the answer for this one i think
you know you're talking about all the
nato allies they might give variations
on a thing but i think all of those
factors would be relevant um there's
probably a psychological confidence as
well uh without the us and i think
you're right to say we need to look at
our own uh capabilities and and uh to do
so in concert with our partners if you
look at the integrated review one of the
things we talked about is the importance
and the ability to operate in a more
agile way with clusters of like-minded
countries and this is already part of
the uh the strategic
analysis uh notwithstanding that of
course the us will remain our closest
down
one of your predecessors in your office
once said in a meeting when i was still
in uniform that if we don't have the
capability we don't have the
responsibility would you agree with that
absolutely and
you know since
international relations theory there's
always been a crucial question have you
reconciled your ends and your means i
think that is clearly from 2001 right
the way through over 20 years a question
i'm not saying that the last two years
that's on our watch we take
responsibility for it that's why i'm
here i do think there are questions
about uh
what was the mission how it adapted have
we at every stage reconciled our means
with our ends
and what the exit looked like in a
realistic and credible way but that is a
much more strategic and i suspect
historic question uh as well as all of
the lessons we're learning now thank you
sorry very brief one from stuart and
then i'm going to royston recording
christian can i just take you back to
the the point you made about the the
cover and the rotors that you just
mentioned
my understanding is all military leave
was cancelled on the 23rd of july
did you initiate a similar process for
the foreign office no what i did was
make sure
that we had
cover
a decent rotor system because you didn't
know for how long this would endure of
course we were pressing for an extension
of the window
in which case you need to make sure with
an emergency response team and indeed
your team in theatre that you're able to
to resource those properly but also make
sure that you can rotate them otherwise
you've got a much greater risk of
mistakes happening i think many would
think that if all military leave was
cancelled on the 23rd of july it was a
bad idea for yourself the prime minister
and several other officials
in the fcd or the home office and the
mod
to take breaks at that time but i'll
leave it to that
we'll move on uh royston thank you
chairman i think we'll try moving on a
bit um
we've spoken to ngos and others have
been on the ground in afghanistan
looking after communities
for a longer period of time than we've
been deployed and of course they'll be
worried about what comes next foreign
secretary you said that you would use um
sanctions aid and access to the
international
uh
monetary financial system in order to
put pressure on the taliban how do you
propose to do that and do you think that
will have an impact on
the afghan people clearly we've got to
try and be discerning between the
pressure we seek to rightly apply leave
as we've got at our disposal on the
taliban whilst not exacerbating the
situation the
um ordinary afghans but there are some
things um so for example
we of course want to get the
humanitarian aid to those who need it
most i think there's going to be an
interesting question about what kind of
support we can provide for neighbouring
countries we've got track record of
doing that for example um
with the rohingya refugees that
went into other countries so what aid
can we produce for that i think we do
need to talk seriously with taliban i
think it's one of the early tests will
they allow permissive environment for un
and humanitarian agencies uh to act if
so of course we've doubled our age eight
to 286 million for afghanistan this year
um we've got allocated uh
30 million for regional partners we want
to make sure the aid gets to those that
need it most i also think there's a
strategic piece again in the integrated
movie we talk about this about the
regional stability that we need which
will be dependent on
the fragility of the situation not in
afghanistan not ending up with wholesale
collapse
what we need to do is set some early
tests
for the taliban i'm realistic as others
have said
about the taliban but they did at least
show in the context
of the evacuation from the airport that
they could communicate a message in
undertaking and broadly with some
exceptions on the ground that roadblocks
follow through on it
it's important then to set further tests
and judge them by their ability to
behave in a reasonable and constructive
way and that will be critical for the
humanitarian lifeline
so
i mean we it was occurring it was a
military coalition of several countries
um will this be a coalition
of how we use aid and how we allow the
taliban access to the uh you know the
world bank and the rest or is it going
to be something the uk will do
unilaterally and if necessary will we
and do we have the capacity to do that
well we believe in doing uh playing a
role playing a leading role that's why
we've announced the resettlement scheme
it's why we've done what we've done to
double odor to 286 million pounds this
year
but crucially britain can't deal with
the humanitarian situation certainly not
the refugee uh crisis alone so what you
hope to do is lead by example and then
galvanize others and that's why the g7
has been important that's why the g7
with the qataris
turkey
the nato secretary general is important
that's why we have circulated the g7
paper which is articulating these things
because we do need
a security mindful response but also a
humanitarian response
i think
but it will be stepping stones towards
this because
of the tensions between many of the
regional partners that we need a contact
group an international contact group
there's been contact groups before
in the context of yugoslavia and other
countries and what you need is to get
the membership there the key regional
players that are influential with the
taliban i think the key western but also
the gulf countries which will
provide support will not want to see
afghanistan disintegrate and that is the
way again as i say to deal with the
problem but also exercise that maximum
moderating influence on the taliban so i
if the answer to your question will the
the
the group of countries required to fix
this the situation now uh be different
in its constellation than the nato
alliance before almost undoubtedly it
will need to bring in a wider group of
actors
and and just
uh looking at the u.s pulling out in the
way that they did and and you know we
could talk about that all day long about
whether we thought that was the right
thing to do
do you see those as being instrumental
in whatever we decide going forward by
way of using these levers to get the
taliban behaving the way that we would
like and in the effect that they don't
do we see any external
others like russia or china making that
more difficult for us you know we could
all be throwing our aid around but who's
going to get the best bang for the buck
and i don't mean looking after people
that's a given but i mean whether or not
we invest in a in a government which is
what the taliban are
that we disagree with and don't do
things the way we want them to we will
not recognize the taliban i believe the
us and
most of the like-minded
g7 countries uh all that said the same
but what we will do is test them and
judge them by how they respond
i think we'll need as i said a much
broader caucus of countries
involved in trying
to resolve this
there's
you know
the united states is going to remain uh
engaged uh and responsible for what
happens next and of course we want to
work very closely
with them
thank you
neil very quickly
close to the u.s and described him as
our closest ally but they didn't talk to
you about uh the closing bhagam airport
and they refused a british request for
an extension in kabul
and in march the government was talking
about alternative alliance to extend
time if needed for the evacuation
instead nine thousand were left behind
because no alliance was formed so why is
global britain so isolated compared to
the great britain under microfactorial
tony blair
well neil i don't think we were alone in
trying to see what flexibility there was
to extend the
window
to happen and with the united states no
but i i
think the us the uk was not alone uh
impressing those issues and the reality
is for all the sort of
hyperbole you're deploying what we've
got to do is face the new reality as i
said i i thought there was too much
wishful thinking about the consensus in
u.s politics across the isles about what
was actually going to do the
the the the debate around forever wars
um i thought was quite clear uh and
where it was going to end up and how
much was going to change under a new
administration
and we need to be mindful of that
because the consensus in the u.s has
shifted on that and that reflects um uh
a broad political and i guess
underpinning that the public view uh of
those conflicts
but uh that doesn't mean um
that's a reflection frankly on the
politics in the u.s we still believe in
being an open outward looking
internationalist country i know the us
does as well
i think there's a much bigger question
around
effectively nation building in such
inhospitable climates i'm not saying
we shouldn't want and promote liberal
democracy and values around the world i
think we should but again it comes back
tom to the point about reconciling ends
with means
and certainly i think that will be if we
look back at the 20-year period of
afghanistan 2001 to
2021 i think
you know that would be an important
question for us to ask ourselves
um claudia you wanted to come in thank
you chair
40 billion the cost to the uk
2.25 trillion that costs to the us
hundreds of thousands of lives lost 18.4
million people including 10 million
children requiring humanitarian aid
18 months we had to prepare for our exit
it just doesn't seem credible i've
listened carefully in terms of the chaos
that's on the ground the chaos that
there was it just doesn't seem credible
that you were missing in action
are you the person to take us forward
and will you now again consider your
position look um i i understand why you
would want to use this committee to
engage in
the politics of this
we're very clear
about the plan forward i've talked it
through in some detail it involves
dealing with safe passage for those that
have been left behind in afghanistan it
involves the international strategy
around counterterrorism humanitarian
relief the regional stability uh
that we need i think there are lots of
lessons to be learned
from
how we were caught out by the speed and
the scale of the fall of kabul but
claudia
from the uk the us through nato allies
and indeed the taliban and many ordinary
afghans themselves
were surprised by the pace of events of
course we need to learn the lessons of
that but i don't think
it is right accurate to suggest that the
uk was alone
in uh in thinking it would take longer
and it would be more incremental in
terms of the deterioration of the
situation and the grant the
consolidation of control by the taliban
well you know france started their
evacuation way back in may they told you
this is just nonsense they you're
comparing uh you're just not comparing
like for like
the in terms of you know we've had
for 40 years
of a western intervention occupation
in afghanistan destabilizing
afghanistan and the entire region in
effect um
laying the way if you like
for civil wars
what is your understanding of
um
the civil wars in afghanistan and what's
your what would be your approach
i'm sure the 40 years was all western i
think the the russians were in there
before
claudia but clearly there are lessons to
be learned
about
the ability
and the the way in which a campaign
primarily focused on counter-terrorism
morphed into something like into
nation-building
we don't want to give up our ideals our
ambition
uh our attachment to liberal democracy
and open societies but we do need as tom
has mentioned i think i've picked up on
a couple of times now to reconcile our
ends with our means to deliver them
particularly of course in a wider global
context where power has become more
widely dispersed with the rise of the
east
okay oh briefly give us a final question
in two parts firstly in the 18 months
when trump went and the trump
administration talked to the taliban
behind the backs of the afghan
government and indeed not really talking
to us be very clear to us was there more
that we could have been doing to shape
uh perceptions and understanding in the
us because as the chairman said south
korea is not seen as a forever war the
cyprus deployment is not seen as a
forever war these are enduring
commitments why wasn't afghanistan seen
as an enduring commitment in that 18
months could we have reframed that
debate and linked that can we still
actually trust the us
uh as a global partner
so i talked through the back channel
that we had um just to say so we were
monitoring this very carefully
assiduously and we talked about all of
the conversations and the calls and the
various uh contacts that i had since the
by demonstration we were doing exactly
the same
with president trump with my opposite
member mike pompeo
previously um so i i think we've got to
recognize that the support domestically
in the us but those kinds of
interventions clearly fall in the way um
and i'm not sure i agree bob but i
respect you and tom for saying that the
analogies with those longer standing
effectively some of those peacekeeping
operations compared to what was going
what has been happening in afghanistan
so there's a question of what
our polities our public will be willing
to support i have absolutely no doubt
that for all the criticism of uh the us
over this and indeed the uk the u.s will
bounce back it is indispensable
and we work with it uh closely uh not
just on
the evacuation where the coordination
was very strong on the ground um i spoke
to tony blinken right the way through
regularly
bilaterally as well as on the nato and
the g7
calls um and we'll learn the lessons
together um but as we've set out in the
ir um we you know we america's our
closest ally but we are also looking as
we have been for some time about the
agile clusters of countries that we can
operate with whether it's diplomatic or
another context uh i you know it's
probably not for today but i can give
you examples
and i'm sure we'll come to it in due
course it is however
quite striking
uh that this major decision had did
happen
without as much warning as i know many
of us would have wished can i just uh
there's a few clear up points i'm going
to just come to a very specific point
those who applied under the fco scheme
leave of entry outside the rules you
catch that sorry those who applied
uh for uh protection under the leave of
entry outside the rules the one that the
fco managed you'll be aware and forgive
me this is entirely personal but as you
know that i do have a very personal
interest here over the four years that i
served in afghanistan i uh employed at
various points many different
interpreters one of them who worked for
me
applied under that scheme and
he
had to apply in uh via me on the 13th
the 14th and 15th the 16th 21st the 22nd
23rd 24th until he was finally called
forward on the 25th
when he finally uh didn't get through
into kabul airport he managed to make it
to a border and you'll forgive me for
not identifying where at this point
and has
been struggling
to have that
permit as it were that
agreement
ratified for his onward travel into
this next country could you just confirm
that anybody who applied and was
accepted under leave of entry outside
the rules
will have their permissions guaranteed
so first of all
as you know i'm very familiar with your
case i know you are and i'm grateful for
your team for everything
we can and the the challenge
for for all of these cases is uh any
third country that is going to want to
be willing to process uh
certain ones i've spoken to is going to
want to know that there is a
an absolute undertaking to take the
individuals and uh so we take they'll
take them we'll identify them and then
we'll process them and bring them home
i think there is a very real question uh
beyond the question of strict uk
nationals um where of course we're
duty-bound to take them home but there
is a question of the security checks and
how we will operate that so forgive me
while we work through the details i've
been talking to the home secretary of
the defense secretary about this and we
work through the details
have come up with a workable i accept
this
foreign and then come back we want to
come up with a workable situation where
we can give effect to all the
undertakings
that we've made but at the same time i
think rightly be very careful that we
don't end up allowing people back to the
uk who might pose us a threat i
understand all of that foreign secretary
it's just that had he managed to get
onto the air head on the 25th of august
nobody's fault and certainly not yours
that he didn't make it through the press
of crowds but had he made it onto the
airhead on the 24th 5th of august he
would have probably been in the uk by
the 26th
as it is
because he didn't he finds himself on
the border
and unable to pass through
uh a week later and it just it seems
slightly incongruous that he could have
got a direct flight but he can't get an
indirect one because the terms of the
deal seem to have changed in the last
five days and i'm sure that's a
bureaucratic issue rather than a policy
change i was just wondering if you could
clarify that again
forgive me for not delving into the
individual case for the reasons
but i don't think it's just a
bureaucratic issue the question is how
we can make sure that we have proper
assurances around security well you must
have had them before you gave permission
on the 25th surely well
these are the issues that we're working
through so we want to be able to do this
in a workable and secure way i i think
people would look
for all the pressures that you rightly
press and i will you know we will keep a
very close eye on what we can do in this
individual case and others i think uh uh
i mean we would be facing a whole
different range of questions of course
tom if we didn't make sure that we
weren't careful around the security
checks for those coming in i completely
accept that foreign secretary and i'm
sure people would be concerned if they
felt that we'd been cavalier on the 25th
but with stricture on the first for
example i'm sure that would raise
concerns as well so i'd just be grateful
if you can clarify that may i just uh
ask as well there are many people and it
was reported that many people who wrote
on the afghan special cases emailed to
the fcdo may or may not have been opened
anybody who has filed an application
under leave of entry outside the rules
is the foreign office going to accept
that entry or must they resubmit
so um
on the uh the emails and i've gone
through that we we we're triaging them
to the various different schemes sure
and we will get back and make sure
that my commitment is to make sure that
we stand to reply to all mp's emails
certainly the ones that received by the
30th of august because of course new
ones coming in all the time uh by
closing play on monday the 6th of
september
we will read and assess all the other
emails received by the 30th of august by
close of play on monday the 6th of
september and then we'll be in a
position to signpost uh to the best
advice
that we can give them in terms of the
new phase and access out by third place
and there will still be three categories
there will be as there were the home
office category for british nationals
there'll be the leave of entry outside
the rules under the foreign office and
arab under the ministry of defense is
that correct well the leave outside the
rules will
transition into the broader resettlement
criteria which are obviously based on
objective criteria around asylum but of
course we're looking very carefully at
those cases particularly the cases that
were called forward
so anybody who was called forward may or
may not still have an extent permission
to come to the uk depending on the
change in the rules we want to make sure
of those that were called forward sorry
forgive me i accept you want to make it
sure but are they currently still able
to travel or is
is that now expired
but in terms of able to travel that will
depend but if they make it to pakistan
the issue we've got to reconcile in
relation to non-uk nationals is the
security checks uh before individuals
get to a third country where they will
automatically be expected to come home i
think it's right we make sure we work
through that
okay and
you mentioned emails to members of
parliament there are many others as you
know who are submitting emails on behalf
of people including of course aid
agencies will you make that commitment
as well for them
well responding to aid agencies in the
same way as you said you're going to
respond to mps by the 6th of september
let me
look at what we can
do on that we want to get back to
everyone the reality is by the way the
reason the backlog built up is not just
um
the search for the door in the narrowing
window lots of mps quite rightly and
others looking for multiple updates
we made a conscious decision so i want
to be honest about this to say okay
we can answer every email that we get or
we can focus resource on getting uh as
many eligible people
through kabul onto air flights filling
capacity back home
and i think that was still the right
choice and i think the numbers bear that
out but of course i'm very conscious of
the need to give people update and then
a sense of
signposting as to where to go next with
the advice
we are committed to fulfilling the
undertakings we've already made but it's
more difficult now of course
i thought i thought that
that um michael gove was chairing a
group that was looking at the criteria
but you you seem to be announcing now
that the criteria um for the afghan
resettlement scheme will be asylum
no no no
that's not the case but they're not
going to be i mean they're going to be a
different
set of cases from the arab workers and
the nationals the criteria uh
right um
uh i mean the truth is uh
i'm working that through with the home
secretary um but of course though we'll
want to work very closely with the un
and other organizations because it is
wider than just the question of the
individuals who are currently if you
like uh
on the emails or uh the special cases or
the current lotter yes not least because
there's the hazara community what's your
assessment others i mean people have
raised the lgbt community yeah we need a
little bit we do need to look at this in
the round i know but i just want you to
go to answer the point about the hazara
community is it your understanding
i know you won't want to use the word
genocide we've been around that battle
many times but um the taliban have
referred themselves to genocide against
the hazara people
is that your assassin
is there a deliberate attempt by taliban
to kill hazara well
look we are very anxious for their
vulnerability i'm not sure
the evidence hits the tripwire for that
yet but of course as you know i i think
that becomes a bit of a distraction from
the point of view of trying to provide
protection for long-term people of
course we want to look at them and all
the other ethnic minority groups sikhs
and others who are vulnerable at this
point in time
it's just that all the cases that i've
sent through come from that community
and i know that applies to quite a lot
of
people
very carefully
but that's all the more reason because
there'll be different people with
different communities to look at this in
the round which is what okay
can i just
challenge you on this question about
phone numbers that haven't worked
because the number that mps were given
you rang it it rang for ages and ages
and ages nobody answered it and then
eventually it said please send an email
to the following when you sent an email
to that email address it bounced back
with the things saying please ring this
telephone number can i just challenge
that because i i i knew that this would
be asked and i went and got the data and
i could tell you what the data is
between the 16th of august and the 26th
the average waiting time to to pick up a
call on the mp hotline was under a
minute for the same period for the
public lines it was
a range of between 40 seconds and three
minutes 49 seconds so if someone had a
bad experience
you said that in the chamber i know and
and i
i would ask you just to push to push
back to officials on that because i'm
not
every mp i know has had the same
experience of not being able to get a
telephone that's why i'm checking the
data chris so i'm i came equipped to
give you the answer to your question and
to do it very okay transparently all
right let me do another one um swift one
uh i think you'll have seen the news
night report about embassy staff telling
people to go to the abbey gate
and on the very day of the isis k attack
when the military advice was not to go
look um we changed our travel advice
after afghanistan just after 10 p.m on
wednesday the 25th of august that was
the night before the attack at the same
time we stopped asking british nationals
and afghan nationals whether they were
arap or lotto to come to the airport uh
the military worked very hard to secure
the area um
and we also shifted the civilian team uh
from
the abbey gate the advent sorry the
barons hotel processing center
through to the airport to protect them
so we took all those mitigating measures
and obviously in close consultation with
the us i saw that that report from
newsnight about the email saying go to
abigail i i need to investigate it um
but okay but the general advice as
opposed to individual advice and if
there was a lag we need to look at that
but you will investigate and you'll come
you'll come back to us on that
absolutely
i mean i understand in a chaotic
circumstance it can be very difficult
can i just put one final thing to you
which is you referred to what it's like
working
and how ambassadors report back and it
all gets
melded into one advice
can i just suggest to you that sometimes
there is a danger in the foreign office
of group think
i know you're aware of this because
you've often referred to it yourself and
i just wonder whether sometimes you
wouldn't have been better advised over
the last few months to pick up the phone
to the person on the ground more often
well let me answer that so first of all
we don't just mold it into some
homogenous homogenous
product we have uh ambassadors on those
meetings virtually testing it
i do it all the time i've done it over
the last 48 hours
equally
we've got to use effective use of time
and resource given that and i come back
to the point i made earlier afghanistan
is the issue that has clearly caught us
uh
unawares in terms of the pace and scale
of the taliban um uh
uh grip control
uh imposition of control but there are a
whole range of other issues that we're
dealing with i know but if you don't
learn from this situation about how to
challenge and get better intelligence
and information back we'll do it again
and we'll capitulate again and we will
drag the british through the mud again
chris two things one no one in the fcdo
thinks i don't challenge official advice
uh rigorously um i do uh if anything i
get accused of uh you know
of being over uh inquisitorial and but i
do think it's important and indeed the
foreign office as an institution was
testing and we did across government
that's not to say there aren't lessons
to be learned but you've also got to
look at
and
you know the
the sort of caricature of critique
against me is that i'm either lazy
and delegating too much or a control
freak
the truth is you need to exercise grip
but you also need to be willing to
delegate if you don't do that you will
never take decisions and you will also
never engage with the international
interlocutors whom we need to influence
at taking point we're going to move on
very very briefly claudia then alicia
and then we're just very briefly just on
the issue of aids
aid charities and humanitarian aid i
just wondered
what humanitarian aid and charity
organizations are you aware of on the
ground or your office is aware of wonder
on the ground in terms of engaging with
them
the the so the i spoke to gianno who's
the un uh secretary general's special uh
envoy for afghanistan that clearly the
situation uh for most is very precarious
indeed uh if they can still operate at
all um so we're worried about that um so
the question is which which ones have
have your office or you've been engaged
with uh on the ground well if you want
and if you haven't got that list can you
provide that too
yeah okay and just very
quickly just on the issue of inclusivity
and the issue of minorities
what work is being done with the un to
create safe zones within afghanistan
for religious minorities for lesbian gay
bisexual
plus others communities
what is being done to keep people safe
we already know that inclusivity as far
as the taliban government is concerned
will not include
those groups
look i totally share your concerns
claudia but if you're talking about
safe zones or no-fly zones that would
require
military enforcement and clearly
that is not something that
that is being proposed right now it is
very difficult to see how what you're
quite understandably proposing will be
workable in the absence of uh political
commitment and i i don't see that
there's support for it at the moment
very briefly for me
wants to give their heartfelt gratitude
to all the
foreign rdt desk post neighbouring post
crisis center um can you give us
reassurances that sufficient mental
health and trauma recovery service has
been provided to them and that when
their military colleagues are recognized
we will also recognize those civilians
who did so much to save lives it's
really important point alicia and
not just those that worked in kabul and
so laurie bristow i think i'm sure the
committee will agree did
an incredible job under the most
extraordinary pressure but also people
that man the crisis center
that that was ruling
and of course making some of those
decisions is very difficult
but you've got to make the decisions to
get the maximum people onto the capacity
we have but your broader point is very
well made and we're already doing
everything we can both on the welfare
side but also on the recognition
thank you very much indeed foreign
secretary um we're very grateful that
you uh overstayed
and helped us so much with our inquiry
this is clearly going to be an ongoing
challenging uh question for all of us
and we'd be very grateful if you come
back to us very soon for a follow-up
hearing because this is going to be the
single biggest challenge that i suspect
the uk deals with in terms of redefining
our foreign policy i stand by the view
that this is the single biggest foreign
policy disaster that the uk has faced
since sewers in the sense that it has
exposed a weakness uh in our alliances
and in our stance and i'd be very
interested in hearing when you have time
to actually process it and not just
firefight uh your own views on how this
will change uh how we do foreign policy
i'm very happy to come back to the
committee thank you uh for the rigorous
engagement it's very important and also
to get a factual account i'm afraid i
struggle with the sewers analogy but i
understand what you're really searching
for is to learn the lessons and even
more importantly find a path forward for
afghanistan or generally
thank you very much on that basis order
order
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended